euromaxx highlights and here's your host
guy instead greetings from our studios
in Berlin and welcome to our highlights
edition and we've got quite a lineup of
top stories from the past week in store
for today starting with the following
cooking competition in the Tyrolean town
of iskele chefs vied with one another on
skis and in the kitchen condensed
classic in Berlin the documentary film
the colon ring had its world premiere
famous festival celebrating the arrival
of spring at the feria de abril in
Sevilla well usually they compete for
Michelin stars or even go mio tux but
this time they had to show their skill
and their stamina outside the kitchen as
well the culinary world cup is
essentially a kind of a chef's special
biathlon that brings together about a
hundred top chefs from Germany and
Austria to cook and to flex some muscle
on the beautiful resort of ishka in
Austria played host and we followed one
of Austria's champion chefs through a
grueling event
Johann laughs that slips into his white
crooks jacket but this time he's not
heading for the kitchen on her skis the
Austrian is preparing to square off
against colleagues on an unaccustomed to
rain she can achieve of course everyone
here has ambition someone with no
ambition might as well be dead you have
to show you this time everyone's
watching to see what laugher doesn't
wondering if he can ski as well as could
be fun he's got the will but does he
have the skill nice be happy if I were
already at the bottom when I look down I
have the feeling cooking is easier Johan
Martha is competing in the culinary
world cup against about 100 other top
cooks from the german-speaking world
many of them have restaurants in winter
sports resorts and today they're
competing for fractions of a second the
way they would to win Michelin stars
there's my daddy by putting effort into
it that's like cooking just like in
cooking you can't start simply coasting
that's not a novel as disclosed in my
cooking's a team sport the whole team
has to pull together and here you go out
to the starting line and you're alone
until you reach the finishing line and
then you have lots of friends again it's
I feel you are Baba looey gogoli Johan
lava is slower than most of the other
skiing cooks but he'll have a second
chance in the cooking part of the
competition
here lava heads a team of six cooks
they'll have to prepare a meal from
ingredients assigned to them this is the
first time I've had the feeling that too
many cooks spoil the broth but we're
good we'll manage your coffee's not
complicated at all we have two stars so
everything's fine UNF only has 10
minutes before his filet and champagne
sauce has to be presented to the jury
skiing legends like Mark Jared early and
German TV stars like yohannes bacana and
Marcel rife judge the dish was impressed
they conjure up an entire meal in just
ten minutes so why does it take so long
in a restaurant mr. all so long at the
office parkour scuba it was only briefly
cooked but delicious a good piece of
meat Facebook wood floor whether that's
enough to win the competition will be
revealed at the gala celebration in the
evening Martin zebra chef at a luxury
hotel and ish girl is preparing the meal
for it the centerpiece of one course is
lobster yoanne lafa looks over his
shoulder to test what's in store for the
evening economy Arthur if I had to I
could cook something myself but to be
honest I don't want to stand here and
cook for 350 people of whom 120 to 150
think they're the world's best chefs
seen Alice T best chefs teaser editor
dismiss my hunt le sorry this that's why
I admire his courage is any mood so as a
lab you can I have a taste it's like it
used to be a court I'm the food taster
who screens for poison oak because well
I'd eat it then comes the award ceremony
in skiing the winner is Rudolph Ubar of
Austria as in years past
in the cooking part human lavas team
comes in a close second after hunts
houses team
[ __ ] actually I thought we would win
because our meat was just fantastic and
the source but there are often juries
who don't know what they're doing and
there's nothing you can do but it's nice
to have got away from my daily routine
and done something else I'm motivated it
was fun and now I'm looking forward to
some decent cooking again the first it's
time to celebrate and a chance to talk
shop with other top chefs is even more
important for your home life than
winning the culinary world cup well
anyone who knows opera just a bit will
know that you need some real stamina to
get through works by Richard Wagner at
the best of times the German composers
monumental pieces the Ring cycle that's
a regular operatic marathon at four
separate operas in about 16 hours of
music all told and you can imagine that
it's next to impossible for smaller
theaters to ever even staged a full
performance so a new version specially
conceived for the Teatro colon in Buenos
Aires took a daring approach to the
material and DW now has that story on
film
berlin's Delphie film palast has seen
its fair share of premieres over the
decades Hans Costa fun buck is in superb
spirit his latest film is about to play
to a capacity crowd
the cologne ring vagner in Buenos iris
is a 93 minute documentary film attracts
an extraordinary project staged at the
most famous opera house in Latin America
the Teatro colon and Buenos Aires lashad
Vark nose ring of the knee belong takes
about 16 hours to perform normally over
four evenings the Teatro colon version
was condensed into a single seven our
production quota ankita in and see I
wanted to provide an insider's view of
how modern opera production evolves week
one without any commentary purely from
the perspective of the ensemble's
authors East the Dallas all will be
clear the project got off to a
disastrous start when it's German
director Catalina Vagner
great-granddaughter at the composer made
an early exit as well as kotaku item was
knowing the time to be accommodating
raghava just 42 days before the premiere
through i implement our film is that
it's a bonus for documentary filmmaker
because it adds to the drama intention
oh these that lack of certainty suddenly
opened up new developments it was great
in terms of the film's story Argentinian
choreographer and opera director
Valentina Carrasco stepped into the
bridge with 33 days to go actually I
will probably proposed the duration to
change the name of this link runs upon
it something like the earthquake of the
knee balloon or something because it's
quite shaky but
and know about the mine elf car we
wanted to sign flights a week the last
my dream was to say key card we keep on
shooting and see what happens maybe this
story of downfall in resurrection
they'll be reflected in what we're now
seeing on screen TV get stuffing victim
scene
DW initiated the documentary film and
was responsible editorially responsive
arts why floors the most exciting part
was doing the ring as it's never been
seen before that really interested in
spite the residents in the second thing
that we found interesting was the
intercultural dialogue which is always
been a key issue for Deutsche Welle
classical music has perennial e been a
DW focus large-scale productions like
the Beethoven project or Schumann at
Pier 2 yielded award-winning films the
Cologne bring is to become part of that
tradition
sup shonda's in deformity at last I do
believe that we've done ourselves proud
when it comes to promoting classical
music Germany and Europe today's
production and the one following it now
and their broadcast on deutsche welle
are further pieces in that mosaic is
invited home was a edge style of these
mafia the premiere turned out to be a
huge hit which was a great relief to
everyone who took part in it from victim
kappa every day for six weeks we SAT
with the editors 10 hours each day and
work through all the material and to see
it the way it's been condensed like this
on the big screen is fantastic it's my
bus station
many of the people featured in the film
attended the opening ceremony for them
the vogner marathon continues such as
signing DVDs of the documentary which
they've just seen for the first time the
film magically catches that catches this
balance the worst between difficulty and
an unwilling and fun I thought it was
wonderful I've in a sense that it showed
not just all the positive sides it
showed all the background discussions
and conflicts that we had as well as the
positive outcome the fynbos won't be
seein an aveda building almost like
reliving our time back then as the film
depicts we really did spend it as though
we were sealed off hermetically be
nothing but we didn't see anything
outside the hotel and the Opera House
the condensed seven hour version of the
ring of the knee belong done in one day
at the teatro colon in Buenos iris was a
big success and the documentary by
deutsche welle kept the viewers glued to
their seats as well and also ended with
standing ovations from the audience well
now to one of the most popular festivals
in Spain that's the feria de abril which
is held every year in the Andalusian
capital of seville six full days of
festivities see everyone flocking to the
fairgrounds in traditional costume and
we got in on the fun April in Seville
it's hot but women are wearing long
sleeves men are in suits the locals love
to dress up for the festival for six
days in a row they dance eat and drink
visitors either take a carriage or
stroll through the city it's important
to see and be seen the friends and
family are the priority for us it's a
week we can't miss hit any cost we look
forward to it all year round editor
plumbing women dancing flamenco are more
enchanting than anything else in the
world in laffy it's a typical Spanish
festival in Seville yeah more than 1000
tens have been pitched called cossetta's
most belong to families clubs or
professional associations only invited
guests get in members pay thousands of
euros a year and pass on their
cossetta's to their children and
grandchildren
others have to wait 20 years to get
their own cassetta for locals such as P
loud bang na Maya this is the occasion
to spend time with good friends and
acquaintances if they invite you to
consider it's as if they've invited you
to their home sometimes people have
tourists into family cossetta's that are
actually private in this sense seville
inhabitants are really very open coming
on cuz i gay and this isn't yet some say
exclusivity is why the feria has
remained a local festival but there are
some tourists apart from beer and wine
people like to drink rebolledo sherry
was lemonade tourists who've had their
fill of street entertainment can get
something to eat or drink in a public
casita and the lucky ones might even get
invited to a private tent
the invitation to casa be no very happy
bride flamenco dresses are a key
component of the Fatiha founded in 1847
it was a cattle market that gradually
became more and more of a festival and a
catwalk for flamenco this year black and
red are trendy and long fringes men also
wear traditional garb a short jacket and
a hat called a cordobas other regional
costumes in Spain remaining the same but
here there are always new trends if you
want to wear the same dress two times in
a row you should definitely change
something add something new while some
party others have to work for the
designer Rocio Montero the feria means
big business a customer from Valencia is
coming on the weekend and her new dress
has to be finished in time the
family-owned company Lina has been
making flamenco dresses for over 50
years
Grace Kelly was one of their customers a
tailor-made dress starts out at about
800 euros
maduro que nunca falta un traje a
flamenco dress has to have flounces and
a skirt that's good for dancing yeah a
number of frills their size and where
they're attached changes from one year
to the next and from one designer to the
next poco de cambiar the other thing is
that it should be close fitting so a
woman can dance well that's the point
after all the failure would simply not
be the same without the silly Jana it's
light-hearted music and dance are
popular all over Spain and it's a far
cry from the much heavier flamenco in
fact earlier the men used it to court
the ladies
it in a kitchen boy low and it's not
true that and illusions only have
partying on their mind that's inaccurate
people work study go abroad make a
living but when it's time to get
together with friends and family enjoy
good wine or a cold beer and flamenco
then we do it to our hearts content wait
a minute ice with that and so it's not
so hard to enjoy the good sides of life
at the ferry idea blue in Seville well
many cultures here in Europe associate
breaking glass with the arrival of good
luck and for polish artist mar takla
norske that may very well be true the
49-year old Warsaw native uses carefully
broken shards of glass to create animal
figures that are actually inspired by
paintings from the grandmasters some of
her works are now on show right here in
Berlin but there's no petting allowed
figures from paintings by the old
masters rendered in thousands of pieces
of glass this dog kept watch over his
master in a painting by peter paul
rubens for over 400 years polish
sculptor mata klonoff Scott has now
transported him into another current
dimension offended us interesante I
think it's interesting I turn it back
and that's on my stuff back I really
like to go to exhibitions of the old
masters on Dan Hibiki doctor says I'm
sure in his interest artists there's
always something new to discover from
dicen get married in her school so I
thought it would be interesting to take
something from these paintings and
reinterpreted as something of my own
that niosh Denton dead breath you
panofsky focused on the animals in the
old masterpieces [ __ ] them from the
background and placing them center stage
like this dog from a painting by French
artist Claude Louie delay
the only thing left of his mistress is a
pair of shoes
indeed see a douchebag engine when you
make the rounds of the galleries in
Berlin you might find only one or two
exhibitions of works in class but you'll
find a hundred exhibitions of paintings
100 of photographs and maybe another
hundred featuring videos and
installations glass is a very small
niche location again and that fact alone
makes it interesting land does have
sunday in person it's a niche that clone
obscure is exploring for herself all
kinds of animals can serve as an
inspiration take this goat for instance
in 1630 Flemish baroque painter
Alexander Kyle inch created it in
miniature conosce collects ideas on
visits to museums like Dusseldorf
squinched Palast she became interested
in baroque painting while studying arts
what fascinates her about the work by
Rubens is the way the dog reflects its
masters strength doesn't Alyssa hunlock
father these were all subjects from
before the age of photography and people
wanted to show off prove that they were
there and leave behind a document of
themselves doc woman that's what they
did I mean that positively they put
certain traits are certain situations on
display bazongas base Andre
eigenschaften that's how these paintings
are structured yawns as in ulta Buddha
I'll get out all in her dildo studio
konopka works on a new piece for an
exhibition in Venice it's modeled on a
squirrel from a still life by Flemish
painter Franz Snyder's oh Jesus I
tension this is I this squirrel is a
cute little animal in theory at least in
reality if you look at an enlargement
its predator a favicon outlook it has a
threatening expression well this is big
oh that's what interests me and I'd like
to do an oversized version of it to make
it more abstract and reduce the cuteness
penobscot will need up to three months
to render the painted squirrel in glass
she starts by welding together a frame
made from metal rods while referring to
sketches she's made she then cuts panes
of glass into shards this is the most
challenging part she spends about half
of her working time cutting the pains
into strips then she sticks the shards
onto the sculpture she has to be careful
not to cut herself ah Oh radicchio
Swedish Katara you're gonna find the
problem is knowing when to stop gun to
murder when you get too tired the
concentration drops off and then you
move in ways you shouldn't niche get
mocked fed and zoning it's easy to slit
your hand open seats I know in all her
years of working with razor-sharp edges
montéclin off ska has never seriously
injured herself the sculptor is
currently exhibiting in Berlin her Glass
Menagerie featuring four centuries of
art history and finally when it comes to
phenomena like mental telepathy or
clairvoyance most people usually pass it
off as supernatural hocus-pocus and yet
there are some performers who can get
even the staunchest of naysayers to
start doubting well they call themselves
mentalists and one of the most
successful at the moment is Germany's
very own Kristoff cool he's the 2012
world champion in this mysterious
discipline and so we did our best to get
into his head
mentalist Christophe cook baffles his
audience at a show in Shaba in southern
Germany he can predict the sequence of
an entire deck of cards or numbers even
secret pin numbers
and cold ice
or even locate a hidden horseshoe nail
the mines magic needs no sleight of hand
only trying to see it's nice to see that
something impossible can turn out to be
true okay my list Atari but us it's a
complete surprise I've never imagined
something like this would work a
personal identification number or these
digits at the beginning there are so
many possibilities and he managed to get
it fascinating it's a very strange
feeling when someone knows what you know
or what you're thinking they think of
human elements that I've brought along a
50 cent coin heads and tails yeah you
give me let me give it to you into my
bit nippy and now please place your
hands behind your back decide on one
hand bring your hands forward again and
stretch them out towards me eighty
percent of people slightly point their
nose subconsciously towards the hand
holding the coin first time around like
would you missus get here isn't an
exception at Mattie so please just drop
the coin he meant to be define it
skipped statistic there are statistics
that I obviously try to use in human
[ __ ] if I say and please think of a
simple hand tool most people think of a
hammer and hammer if I say please think
of a flower than most people think of a
rose these are psychological phenomena
you can utilize Natsu Mahan con
christophe kook studied business but his
passion is mental magic as a Mentalist
the 38 year old analyzes psychological
surveys and studies people's gestures
and facial expressions other magicians
do tricks that are technically elaborate
like Hans Klok from the Netherlands
mentalists don't need special effects
they work with the power of suggestion
just like Germany's Nikolai fatally who
became the world mental magic champion
in 2009 in 2012 Christof Koch followed
in his footsteps when he won the World
Championship with a mental experiment
he'd worked on for a decade a volunteer
thinks of a few numbers and jots them
down including a year that a coin was
minted finally the magician hands her a
coin from exactly that year you mean by
this the gristle and stuff I'll give you
a magnifying glass so you can see the
engraving on the coin now turn it round
and look at the debt and yaris anchor
viewed so loud and clear what number do
you see on 1888 when this is really yes
despondent against itself is repeated
the lingering shadow of a doubt you see
in most people is interesting they're
wondering if there's more to it than
just common sense that's fascinating and
15 when people see a magician they know
they're going to be enchanted but they
also always know there's a trick there
to mental magic is different because
they never know where the magic starts
and psychology stops untested so bhai on
one ready to go gyro
audiences worldwide want to see Christof
Koch combined the power of suggestion
with illusion he's even scheduled for a
show with the famous magic castle in Los
Angeles well that brings us to the end
of this edition of our highlights thanks
very much for joining us and until we
meet again from all of us here in Berlin
best wishes Alice cool to choose on
toffee desi